The final episode of Game of Thrones starts
in the ruins of King’s Landing.
Thousands of people are dead because last
episode, Daenerys burned the city.
And now Grey Worm is killing prisoners . He
says that Lannister soldiers are “free men”
who “chose” to fight for Cersei . But
random soldiers don’t really choose – they’re
forced into war by their lord . Feudalism
is kinda similar to slavery.
But Grey Worm has no sympathy, and kills the
Lannisters.
Tyrion sees the small council room, where
he served in the early seasons.
There are so many memories here of Tyrion’s
successes and failures and his family.
Tyrion finds Jaime and Cersei’s bodies under
a surprisingly light dusting of bricks.
Tyrion tried to protect his siblings from
Daenerys , but he supported her war because
he thought she would make the world better
. Now, Daenerys is a tyrant, and Tyrion’s
family’s dead anyway.
So all Tyrion’s work these last seasons
have only brought death to his family and
to thousands of others.
Daenerys goes full Targaryen.
She gives a victory speech to her soldiers,
and it looks just like a Nazi rally, with
Daenerys as Hitler – but with a dragon.
She says she “liberated” the people of
King’s Landing, which is delusional – she
killed those people, after they’d surrendered.
And she says she’ll continue her war, to
‘liberate’ “all the people of the world”
. She mentions Winterfell and Lannisport – threatening
Jon and Tyrion’s family homes.
She also mentions Qarth – in Season 2, Daenerys
threatened to destroy that city . So Daenerys
is set to bring death and destruction to the
world.
That flaming spiral in Episode 1 does look
like the Targaryen sigil.
Turns out the real threat to the world isn’t
icy white walkers – it’s Targaryen fire.
Tyrion quits as Daenerys’ Hand.
And his Hand pin looks like Jaime’s hand
– Tyrion refuses to follow the woman who
killed his family.
Daenerys arrests Tyrion for treason – because
he freed Jaime, and tried to save Cersei .
Arya warns that Daenerys is a threat to Jon,
because Jon is the true heir to the Iron Throne
. Dany’s also a threat to Sansa, because
Sansa won’t accept her as queen . So Daenerys
is not just a threat to the world, she’s
a threat to Jon, and to Tyrion and their families.
Tyrion tells Jon that Varys was right about
Daenerys – she went bad, and supporting
her was wrong.
So when Tyrion ratted out Varys, he got his
friend killed for nothing . Jon tries to defend
Dany, but Tyrion argues that her massacre
was unjust and unnecessary . Tyrion says that
for the sake of their families and the world
, Jon should kill Daenerys – even though
Jon loves Daenerys . So once again, Jon has
to choose between love and duty . This is
like when Jon gave up his love Ygritte to
stop the wildlings.
Now, Jon has to kill Dany to save the world.
This scene is similar to when Varys convinced
Ned Stark to make a false confession – to
do something dishonourable to protect his
family.
Ned was only convinced when Varys mentioned
Sansa’s safety . And now Jon is only convinced
when Tyrion mentions Sansa’s safety . So
Jon is following Ned Stark’s example, even
though Ned isn’t Jon’s father – Rhaegar
Targaryen is.
But as Jon says, people aren’t defined by
their blood – they make their own choices
. And Jon chooses, like Ned, to do the right
thing, even when it costs everything.
Daenerys approaches the Throne.
She’s wanted this for eight seasons, and
it’s not quite how she imagined.
She thought the Throne would be bigger, “a
mountain of swords” – and in the books,
the Throne is much bigger.
Daenerys had a vision of the Throne in Season
2, and this scene recreates it.
But this time, Daenerys touches the Throne.
Jon confronts Dany about the killings and
imprisoning Tyrion.
Dany argues that she has to punish Tyrion
for conspiring with her enemies – just like
Jon has killed people who disobeyed him . But
Daenerys has no justification for killing
the people of King’s Landing.
She just says she’ll build a new world , and
that she knows what’s good, and other people
don’t get to choose . As Tyrion said, Daenerys
has spent years gaining power and killing
people and being rewarded for it.
She’s been surrounded by adoring followers,
people who worship her as messiah.
Daenerys once said that what keeps her going
is “faith” in herself . Now her faith
blinds her to the evil she’s committing.
She’s so convinced of her destiny to destroy
tyranny that she’s become a tyrant . Daenerys
tells Jon to join her, fulfil his destiny,
and rule the galaxy together as nephew and
aunt – and Jon makes his choice.
They embrace one last time, and Jon stabs
his lover in the heart.
It’s like the legend of Azor Ahai, a hero
who sacrificed his lover to save the world.
There are lots of hints in the series that
Jon is this prophesied hero , and it seemed
as though that meant that he would stop the
white walkers.
But in the end, Jon’s destiny is to save
the world from the woman he loves.
Dany dies in his arms like Ygritte – Jon
chose duty over love.
The dragon Drogon sees Daenerys dead.
She was his mother, she hatched him from his
egg.
And a for a moment it looks like he’ll kill
Jon, but instead, Drogon burns the Iron Throne.
Cause in a way, it was the Throne that killed
Daenerys.
The Throne represents power, and all the ways
that power corrupts people.
We saw Cersei and Joffrey and Robert and Stannis
all destroyed by power in different ways.
Wars for the Throne tore Westeros apart, so
the Throne is the real enemy, just as much
the Night King was.
By destroying the Throne, Drogon finally ‘breaks
the wheel’ that Daenerys talked about.
It ends the cycle of conflict in Westeros
– symbolically, at least.
And the Throne is destroyed in dragonfire,
just like it was originally forged in dragonfire.
It’s like the One Ring in Lord of the Rings
– it also symbolises power, and drives people
mad to possess it, and is destroyed in the
fires that forged it.
Drogon takes Dany’s body and flies east.
Dany thought that Westeros would be her home,
but it never felt like home . The east is
where she found love and success, so that’s
where she returns.
In her vision in Season 2, Daenerys leaves
the Throne, then goes to be with her dead
lover Drogo.
Now, in death, Daenerys returns to her love.
Weeks later, a meeting is held with the high
lords of Westeros.
There’s Sansa for the north, Edmure for
the riverlands, Robin for the Vale, Gendry
for the Stormlands, Yara for the Iron Islands,
and the new prince of Dorne.
Grey Worm has Tyrion and Jon prisoner – Tyrion
for his treason , and Jon for killing Daenerys.
Sansa has brought down an army of northmen
to secure Jon . Davos says the Unsullied should
start their own house in the Reach, which
is a weird suggestion – cause the Unsullied
are eunuchs, so how could they start a noble
family?
Grey Worm says he just wants justice for the
murder of Daenerys – so you’d think that
Grey Worm would’ve just executed Jon by
now.
Jon murdered Grey Worm’s queen, surely the
punishment is death.
Why does he wait around to ask Jon’s family
for their opinion?
Tyrion says they need to choose a new king
. And Edmure says he’d like to be king . Edmure
is Sansa’s uncle.
The Red Wedding was his wedding, then he was
imprisoned by the Freys for half the series.
Edmure’s kind of a doofus, so Sansa makes
him sit . Then Sam suggests democracy.
He says the King of Westeros should be chosen
by all the people . Some parts of Westeros
do have elections.
The Night’s Watchmen vote to choose their
leader.
And the ironborn lords elect their king.
But the lords laugh at the idea of giving
peasants a vote – it’s a big step from
feudalism to democracy.
Tyrion says that stories unite people , and
Bran has a great story . As the magic three-eyed
raven, Bran is the world’s memory, he remembers
the past – so he should lead Westeros in
the future . And all the lords agree to make
Bran their king . Which is a very weird choice.
These lords don’t know Bran, and they don’t
know what a three-eyed raven is – they have
no connection to the magic of the old gods
of the north.
Even to his own family, Bran is confusing
and mysterious.
To these southern lords, he’s a creepy foreign
cripple.
Bran also has no claim on the Throne.
For the last three hundred years, the Throne
of Westeros passed down a line of succession.
That’s why Daenerys had a claim, as the
daughter of the Mad King.
Jon Snow has a better claim, as the son of
the Mad King’s firstborn.
Jon also has a pretty good story, and he’s
an actual political leader who people know
and support.
Jon’s identity as the true heir to the Throne
was a mystery built up throughout the whole
series , but his claim is not even mentioned
in this scene.
Tyrion says they should ignore the line of
succession, cause the sons of kings are often
terrible like Joffrey.
Ending the line of succession is ‘breaking
the wheel’ , it’s stopping a bad system.
But this could also lead to more conflict.
Tyrion says that each new king will be chosen
by the lords of Westeros . Which means every
time a king dies, there’ll be new uncertainty.
At least the old system had the stability
of a royal family – now, anyone can be king,
so it could turn into a free-for-all every
time a king dies.
Sansa says that the north will be independent
from this new realm . All the other kingdoms
will be ruled by Bran Stark, but the north
will be ruled by Sansa Stark.
This whole meeting is basically a Stark coup
– their family takes over Westeros, and
for some reason, all the other lords agree.
What happened to their ambitions?
In Season 6, Yara made a deal with Daenerys
that the Iron Islands would be independent
. But now she kinda forgets that and agrees
to be ruled by Bran.
And Dorne has a long history of proud independence,
and they should be in a strong position now,
since their armies were untouched in the recent
wars.
But this unnamed prince hands his kingdom
to the Starks.
This whole story was about ambitious noble
families fighting and scheming for power.
But now, in one scene, all the great houses
agree to give up their power to a weird psychic
kid cause ‘he has a good story’.
Maybe everyone’s just too tired and confused
to argue right now.
But Sansa set a precedent for kingdoms to
secede, so there could be rebellions in the
future.
This brave new realm is delicate and uncertain,
but there is hope.
King Bran represents a different kind of ruler.
Past kings have been bad because they’ve
been proud or cruel or power-hungry.
Bran doesn’t care about power . He has no
pride or cruelty.
He barely has a personality – so in theory,
he’ll be fair and unbiased.
He’ll be a good ruler because he’s inhuman
– which is a very depressing message.
Game of Thrones was always about the struggle
between human good and human evil within each
person . Bran being king suggests that the
solution to human evil isn’t human good,
it’s being not human.
And with the failure of Jaime and Daenerys,
this whole season feels deeply cynical about
the very possibility of human good.
Bran makes Tyrion Hand of the King , which
is another strange choice.
Tyrion totally failed at being Daenerys’
Hand, and he ended up betraying her.
And Tyrion’s widely hated as the Imp – a
kinslayer, kingslayer, and betrayer.
It’s hard to believe that any of these lords
even listened to Tyrion at this meeting . But
Bran says that Tyrion will be Hand as punishment
for his crimes – he’ll spend his life
fixing his mistakes .
The Starks want Jon freed, but Grey Worm wants
justice for Daenerys.
So they make a compromise – Jon is sent
to rejoin the Night’s Watch , where he was
in Season 1.
The purpose of the Watch was to defend the
realm from white walkers and wildlings.
Now, the walkers are gone, and the wildlings
are friendly, so Tyrion says the Watch will
just be like a penal colony for “bastards
and broken men” . Jon feels guilty and conflicted
for killing Dany.
She was a threat to his family and the world,
but Daenerys trusted and loved Jon.
Daenerys was Jon’s queen, and she was his
aunt, which makes Jon a kinslayer – a terrible
crime in Westeros . This makes Jon the last
Targaryen – and as Aemon once said, “A
Targaryen alone in the world is a terrible
thing” . Tyrion says he’ll visit Jon – that
he’ll come and “piss off the edge of the
world” , like when he visited in Season
1.
We see some Dothraki at the docks.
In Episode 3, it seemed like all the Dothraki
died , but apparently many survived to the
end.
These guys were fanatically loyal to Daenerys,
they saw her rise from fire twice – and
they followed her across the world to win
her Westeros – so how’d they react to
Dany’s death?
In Season 6, Dany made all her Dothraki her
blood riders , her sworn protectors.
The books say that if a khal is killed, his
blood riders live to avenge him . So surely
when Jon killed Dany, her blood riders would
be honorbound to kill Jon.
But here, the Dothraki just walk past Jon.
They don’t even react to the man who killed
their khaleesi.
What are the Dothraki doing now that Dany
is dead?
When Drogo died in Season 1, his khalasar
scattered into warring factions.
The Dothraki way of life is to raid and pillage
other people . In Season 1, Daenerys was conflicted,
cause she knew that invading Westeros with
Dothraki would have serious consequences . But
the show never explores how the Dothraki and
Westerosi get along – there’s only one
named Dothraki in Season 8, who only gets
one line.
The Dothraki were part of Dany’s story all
series, but in the end they get no closure.
Grey Worm and the Unsullied sail to Naath
. Because Naath is Missandei’s home.
They dreamed of returning there together , and
for the Unsullied to protect the Naathi – so
Grey Worm is honouring his dead girlfriend’s
memory.
In the books, Naath has a disease carried
by butterflies that kills foreigners, so hopefully
that’s not a thing in the show.
But now that the Unsullied are gone, who’s
forcing Jon to stay at the Wall?
You’d think most people would be glad that
Jon killed the tyrant who burned King’s
Landing.
King Robert pardoned Jaime for killing the
Mad King.
Why doesn’t King Bran pardon Jon for killing
the Mad Queen?
As the last Targaryen, some people are gonna
wanna make Jon king.
Staying at the Night’s Watch can be a way
of staying out of politics.
That’s why Aemon joined the Night’s Watch.
Years ago, Aemon was almost made King of Westeros,
but instead, he chose to join the Watch, and
give up his claim, so that his brother could
be king instead . Maybe Jon is staying at
the Watch so his brother Bran can be king.
Another sacrifice for the good of the realm.
Jon farewells his family at the docks, like
Frodo in Lord of the Rings.
And Sansa apologises for having Jon sent north
. She should probably also apologise for breaking
her oath and revealing Jon’s parentage to
undermine Daenerys.
That contributed to the conflict that drove
Dany mad and got Jon exiled – removing Jon
as King in the North – and making Sansa
queen.
Last season, Arya accused Sansa of undermining
Jon so that she can rule the north . And that’s
kinda what ends up happening.
Sansa uses information to create chaos and
climb to power – which is exactly the strategy
used by her mentor Littlefinger.
In Season 1, Sansa was a naïve girl who dreamed
of being a queen . But she learned that queens
and princes aren’t as wonderful as she thought
. To survive, Sansa learned politics from
the worst people in Westeros – like Littlefinger
and Cersei and Ramsay , and those people made
Sansa who she is now . So it is a triumphant
moment that someone who was abused for so
long finally gets power of her own.
And no doubt, Sansa will be a strong ruler
of the north.
She won’t make the mistakes that Ned and
Robb and Jon made.
But there’s something dark in that Sansa
got here by embracing the lessons of her abusers
.
Arya says she’s not coming home – she’s
sailing west, to discover new lands , as she
said she would in Season 6 . So Arya is rejecting
a life as a noble lady, and rejecting the
violence of being an assassin.
Her story was always intertwined with death
– but now she’s killed the Night King,
she’s defeated death, and she chooses a
life of adventure and freedom instead.
But she’s also abandoning her family.
In Season 6, she declared she was Arya Stark,
and her home was Winterfell . But in Season
7, when she tried to reconnect, she ended
up almost murdering her sister.
After everything she’s been through, Arya
feels unable to come home.
Like Frodo, she’s damaged, so she’s sails
into the sunset sea – it’s kind of a metaphor
for death.
And practically speaking, everyone else who’s
sailed west hasn’t returned.
Like this is some Columbus Magellan edge-of-the-world
type shit, and Arya’s not exactly an expert
sailor.
So Arya is letting go of her old lives.
But she keeps Needle – a symbol of her home
and family.
Bran makes a weird comment that Jon was exactly
where he was “supposed to be” . At the
council, he hinted that becoming king was
Bran’s destiny all along . Bran has had
visions of the future before.
And it seems like Bran guided recent events
– he gave Arya the dagger than she used
to kill the Night King.
And he told Sam to tell Jon about his parentage
– which divided Jon from Dany, leading to
her death and his exile, clearing the way
for Bran to become king.
Like Sansa, Bran spread information that created
conflict that gave Bran power – like Littlefinger
does.
In Season 7, Littlefinger gave Bran Arya’s
dagger, and Bran quoted Littlefinger’s line
that “Chaos is a ladder” . Littlefinger
once said you should see all possibilities
in your mind all the time , which is kinda
what Bran does as the magic three-eyed raven.
So did Bran manipulate everything to become
king?
It would be pretty evil if Bran knew that
King’s Landing would burn, but he made it
happen anyway.
But that’s exactly the sort of magic Machiavellian
shit that the three-eyed raven does.
Like, the previous raven used visions to lure
a crippled boy to a cave full of skulls, and
deleted his personality to make him an avatar
for the magic of the old gods.
In the books, the raven is called Bloodraven,
and he has an even longer history of doing
terrible things for the sake of some vague
prophetic greater good.
Bran Stark as we knew him is dead.
Bran said that he’s not Bran any more , he’s
the three-eyed raven now.
So given the raven’s long history of psychic
fuckery, it’s very possible that Bran has
manipulated everyone around him to gain power,
and what we call is Bran is now really a puppet,
a host for the ancient psychic hivemind of
the old gods.
What if the raven never gives up power?
The previous raven said he’s been alive
a thousand years , sustained by the weirwood
roots.
Maybe Bran will become an immortal god-emperor
like in 40K or Dune.
Author George Martin’s old sci-fi stories
are full of evil hive minds doing crazy shit
like this.
But the show mostly avoids the high-magic
stuff, so Bran is left ambiguous.
What he is and what kind of king he’ll be
is open to speculation.
Brienne becomes Commander of the Kingsguard
– the highest and most respected position
for a knight of Westeros.
And there’s a new symbol on the Kingsguard
armour.
In Targaryen times, the armour had a Targaryen
dragon.
Under Robert, it was a crown.
When Tommen joined the sparrows, it was the
Faith’s star.
And now it’s a three-eyed raven, to represent
Bran.
This highlights again how weird it is to make
Bran king.
Cause the raven is a mysterious mystical figure
of the children of the forest and the old
gods, who are only* worshipped in the north
– and the north isn’t even part of Bran’s
realm.
This’d be like if the USA used a Canadian
maple leaf to represent their presidency – culturally
and politically it’s just jarring.
But as Commander of the Kingsguard, it’s
Brienne’s job to update the White Book,
which records the accomplishments of every
Kingsguard knight.
Jaime’s page had no great achievements , so
he hoped to get some good deeds in there before
he died . So now, Brienne fills in Jaime’s
page.
He took Riverrun peacefully.
He outsmarted Daenerys’ war plans.
And he helped the living save the world from
the dead.
Brienne writes that Jaime rode south to save
King’s Landing from destruction, which is
not really true.
Jaime said he went south to be with Cersei.
He said “She's hateful.
And so am I” , and he died saying he and
Cersei are all that matter in the world . Jaime
died hateful, and his redemption failed.
But one of the great lines in the books is
that “Men’s lives have meaning, not their
deaths” . Jaime’s death was a failure,
but he did great things in his life – and
maybe that’s what matters in the end.
This room is where Jaime gave Brienne the
sword Oathkeeper, and showed her the trust
and respect that she needed – so the legacy
of Jaime’s good deeds lives on even if Jaime
failed in death.
Also apparently Podrick has become a Kingsguard
knight, and it’s great that he’s rewarded,
but Kingsguard knights swear vows of chastity,
they’re not allowed to have sex – which
seems a terrible waste of Pod the Rod.
The small council is the government of this
brave new realm.
Tyrion is Hand, Davos Master of Ships, Sam
is Grand Maester, Bronn Master of Coin, and
Brienne’s there as Commander of the Kingsguard.
It’s surprising that Sam is Grand Maester,
cause becoming a maester takes years of study
– Sam just scrubbed bedpans, stole books
and ran, so is he qualified to represent the
Citadel?
And maesters take vows of chastity, they’re
not meant to have children and wildling girlfriends.
Maybe the rules have changed.
But Bronn as Master of Coin is even more questionable.
What does he know about responsible fiscal
management?
A few seasons ago, he said himself that he
doesn’t know how loans work . And that’ll
be a problem, cause the Throne owes money
to the Iron Bank – Cersei never paid back
her Golden Company loan.
We’ve been warned all series that the Iron
Bank is ruthless – they might start a war
if they don’t get their money . After all
these years of expensive conflict , Westeros
could face financial crisis – and it’s
up to Bronn to prevent this.
Bronn is also Lord of Highgarden, and Lord
of the Reach – Tyrion kept his ridiculous
promise and made Bronn one of the most powerful
lords in Westeros – even though Bronn is
a disloyal amoral murderer who threatened
to kill Tyrion just two episodes ago.
There are many powerful houses in the reach
who’ve wanted Highgarden for centuries – they’re
not gonna easily accept Bronn as the overlord.
Tyrion always said that he pays his debts,
and he’s Bronn deserves a reward for eight
seasons of service to the Lannisters.
But giving Bronn this much power is not a
recipe for peace.
Sam has a new history book about the recent
wars . It’s called “A Song of Ice and
Fire”, which is the title of the Game of
Thrones book series – it’s how there’s
a Lord of the Rings book at the end of Lord
of the Rings.
Thrones author George Martin has said that
that Sam is the character most like him , so
it’s appropriate that Sam presents this
book.
Tyrion is upset to learn that he’s not mentioned
in the book.
Realistically, Tyrion would be mentioned – he
was Hand to a king and queen, he killed Tywin,
and supposedly killed Joffrey.
But this is a reference to what Varys said
in Season 2 – that Tyrion will never get
recognition, and the histories won’t mention
him , because he’s a dwarf and a misfit,
he’ll always be misunderstood and hated.
But that only makes Tyrion more heroic for
fighting to make the world better anyway.
King Bran arrives and says they need a Master
of War , which is ominous.
The Master of War position was invented by
Cersei . You’d hope that this new regime
would wanna emphasise peace, not continue
Cersei’s legacy.
Bran also says they need a Master of Whisperers
, which is a spymaster, like Varys.
And you’d think Bran could just do that
himself, since he can spy with animals, and
has visions, and claims to “see everything”
. In the books, the previous three-eyed raven
was once the Master of Whisperers, and used
his magic and spying to basically run the
realm for decades.
King Bran really is a continuation of his
legacy.
Sam says that Drogon is flying towards Volantis
. If he continues that way, he’ll reach
Valyria – the ruined empire of the dragonlords,
and homeland of the Targaryens.
We saw Drogon in Valyria before.
So maybe he and Daenerys are going back to
their ancestral home.
Bran says he might find Drogon with his magic,
but he doesn’t say why.
Does he wanna make sure that Drogon’s safely
far away?
Or does the three-eyed raven have some sinister
plan?
Bran lets the council do the ruling while
he goes and does whatever the three-eyed raven
does.
The last line of dialogue in Game of Thrones
is Tyrion telling his joke about the honeycomb
and the jackass , but once again we don’t
get to hear the punchline.
The scene pans out, and we see the map of
Westeros – it’s cleared of rubble, but
there’s still a crack in the floor.
Cause this new realm isn’t perfect.
There are problems and divisions, and the
king is possibly an evil tree.
But there are good people in government, and
there’s hope that the wounds will heal.
The final scene in Game of Thrones has Jon
and the wildlings riding north.
It seems like Jon is escorting the wildlings,
or maybe he’s abandoning the Night’s Watch
and joining the wildlings.
He reunites with Ghost and Tormund – maybe
he’ll spend his life with friends and have
some fun for once instead of freezing his
ass off on the Wall.
The scene recreates shots from the first scene
in the series, with rangers riding north.
These rangers were hunting wildlings, and
got killed by white walkers.
Winter was rising against them.
But now, the Watch is friendly with the wildlings,
the walkers are gone, and it seems like winter
is ending.
The first line in the Game of Thrones books
is “We should start back” . But as Jon
and the wildlings ride north, it feels like
they’re moving forwards.
Things aren’t perfect, but there’s hope
– it’s a dream of spring.
Author George Martin always said that the
end of Thrones would be bittersweet . And
it was sweet in the show, to see Brienne knighted,
Sansa crowned, Theon redeemed.
We got eight seasons of Lannister drama, Daenerys’
conquests, Jon and Arya’s journeys, adapted
from the books with exceptional production,
acting and music.
The tv show made some nerdy fantasy books
into the biggest thing in pop culture, with
a global community of fans.
[Start showing just S1, fadein other seasons
showing book gap] But it’s bitter that the
show ended before the book series was finished.
So for the last few seasons, the showrunners
didn’t have material to adapt.
They made up their own plots, and tried to
connect them to the book ending that the author
told them.
So sometimes there were dumb plotlines like
the wight hunt.
Sometimes the dialogue was weak cause there
was no book dialogue to use.
Characters like Daenerys and Jaime had sudden
twists in their stories, which felt rushed
and undeveloped because they were squeezed
into shortened seasons.
The politics lost the realism and sense of
consequences that defined the early story.
And the seasons of built up mystery and magic
kinda went nowhere.
Complex characters like Varys and Littlefinger
and Cersei became less important, while asshats
like Euron had huge impacts on the plot without
any character depth to give that impact meaning.
Stuff happened not as a consequence of character
choices or themes, but simply to surprise
the audience.
The main points of the ending on the show
are apparently partly the same as what’s
planned for the books . But the show’s ending
doesn’t have the same depth and detail that
gives the books so much meaning.
So it’s bitter that we didn’t get Daenerys’
conflict with Young Griff from the books.
We didn’t get the horror of book-Euron and
Victarion.
We didn’t get the book Dorne plot, with
Arianne and Quentyn, and Alleras in Oldtown.
Or Sansa with Harry in the Vale, and Barristan
in Meereen, and Marwyn and Moqorro.
Varys and Illyrio’s Blackfyre conspiracy,
and the northern conspiracy.
Rickon on Skagos, and Stannis’ Battle of
Ice.
Lady Stoneheart, Patchface, Strong Belwas,
and Nimble Dick Crabb.
We didn’t get the full prophecies of Azor
Ahai and the valonqar, the mysteries of the
white walkers, the Nightfort, Horn of Winter,
ice spiders and a long Long Night, and everything
else that’ll happen in the next two books.
Martin recently hinted that the next book
will be out in a year . It’ll be sweet to
read his ending.
And it’s sweet that the tv show happened.
But it’s bitter that the show is not what
it could’ve been.
Alt Shift X will make more videos on the Game
of Thrones books.
We’ll also make videos on other series.
There are TV shows coming of Watchmen, His
Dark Materials, Lord of the Rings, Wheel of
Time, and movies of Dune.
There are also Netflix gems like Dark and
Maniac.
So these are the kinds of series we’ll make
videos on in future [YouTube cards vote].
We’ll hold votes and updates on the Alt
Shift X Patreon.
There’ll also be an Alt Shift Podcast about
short stories – subscribe at the link below.
There’s also Alt Shift ZZZ for readings
of old books.
Alt Schwift X is some kind of parody channel(?),
and we don’t endorse it, but it also exists.
The Game of Thrones fan community has been
coming up with theories and analysis since
the 90s – places like Westeros.org, and
the subreddit, the Tumblrs, YouTube channels
and podcasts.
There are too many to name, but you might
like Glidus for some hard-hitting Australian
meme-core Season 8 takedowns.
Thanks to the fan artists, and the caption
translators, and everyone who’s sent nice
messages to Alt Shift X.
None of this would be possible without you
watching and supporting, so thank you.
Thanks also to the Random Article Podcast
for the spiritual guidance, without which
the channel would not exist.
Alt Shift X is taking some time off, there’ll
be no videos for a while, latest updates on
Patreon.
Thanks for watching.
Thanks to Patrons Sam Lundin of House Vimbly,
first of his name, Lord of Union Square, and
Protector of the Realm, thanks to Reverend
Xandria, Cameron Weiss, Michael Appell, Jason
Rattray, Ryan Steele, Eric Louis-Dreyfus,
Triangle Wine Company, Harry, Neel Chopdekar,
Shane Veglia, Jury, Bloody Tyrant, Peter Meehan,
Steven Placencia, LVE, Owen Campbell-Kelly,
Emily McNally, Nikos Moraitakis, Trace Mychal,
Arsh Jhaj, Fred Petty, Chris Cole, Cynbobby
Joe, saif almazrouei, Zach Gordon, and DscoDan.
Cheers.